connaissez-vous cette petite plante qui
aiment les milieux aquatiques
le flux tonnage en apprécient en effet
tous ces milieux qui sont liées à l'eau
comme les berges de rivières les étangs
où les mares malheureusement l'espèce a
vu son aire de répartition diminué suite
aux modifications et à la destruction de
ces zones humides
le parc naturel régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse à participer à des
actions de protection de cette espèce
comme ici dans cette propriété de
clairefontaine en yvelines
progressivement les étangs les mares
sont de moins en moins entretenues donc
curé moins en moins souvent
voilà progressivement toutes les eaux
globalement qu'on rencontre dans les
milieux naturels ont tendance à être
beaucoup plus riche en matière organique
du coup l'espèce a tendance à régresser
à se maintenir que dans quelques petits
milieux un petit peu un peu stable on va
dire notamment marc forestière dans la
forêt domaniale de rambouillet ou sur la
propriété privée ici sur les temps c'est
la seule station de flux tonnage ans du
parc qu'ils soient pas dans la forêt
domaniale donc n'est pas gérée par l'eau
nf notamment dans le cadre de natura
2000 le flux tonnage ans sera inscrit à
un plan national d'action pour la
conservation par le ministère de
l'écologie charge ensuite au
conservatoire botanique national du
bassin parisien d'en rédiger la
déclinaison régionale donc ce plan a
vocation à améliorer l'état de
conservation de l'espèce à l'échelle
nationale aussi d'améliorer la
connaissance que l'on a sur cette espèce
sa répartition et éventuellement des
recherches sur l'écologie sur la
biologie de la reproduction est aussi le
plan national d'action a comme ambition
de fédérer un jeu d'acteur à l'échelle
nationale et de favoriser la
mobilisation des financements pour
mettre en place aux échelles régionale
des programmes de conservation comme par
exemple ici sur l'étang de la petite
verrerie à clairefontaine en yvelines
des travaux de restauration et de curage
des temps ici la propriétaire a donc
reçu une aide financière pour la
réalisation de travaux
prenant en compte la biologie et l'enjeu
de conservation de l'espèce j'ai été un
peu étonné parce que a priori je ne
voyais pas dans mon plan draps mais bien
sûr j'allais les ait permis d'entrée et
nous sommes allés
étant c'est comme ça que l'aventuré
commencé ça ne m'a pas fait peur du tout
pas du tout au contraire se dit qu'on
avait des travaux à faire sur les temps
donc on était assez content tout les
deux n'est ce pas d'avoir rejoint quant
à partir du bureau ont entendu qu'on
allait avoir des subventions
donc nous ça nous intéressait beaucoup
les temps paraît superbe beaucoup plus
beau cadeau à oui on est ravi à l'heure
actuelle l'espèce se maintient dans
plusieurs pays comme la belgique le
danemark la suède
mais c'est en france qu'elle est la plus
présente